what's up everybody you're watching
Marvel live and we are here with Anthony
and Joe Russo as well as Sebastian Stan
from Marvel Studios eventually endgame
uh just a smattering of applause you
guys just came out of the signing what
was the highlight of the signing here at
the Marvel booth today for you guys I
mean it's always great to see the fans
and how excited they are and for us it's
the reason we make the movies and
whenever you can interact with the fans
or meet them hear their stories I mean
it's always it always warms your heart
when somebody says you know I started
watching these when I was 11 and I'm 21
and I grew up with these or they brought
me and my father closer together or you
know granddaughter and a grandmother
just the way that these movies can bind
people and create a sense of community
it's really special
I love that good I mean and you are in
the middle of this incredible incredible
victory lap for Marvel's news Avengers
end game this beautiful beautiful movie
what has it been like seeing fans you
said the experience of like fans coming
up to you and like telling you all these
amazing stories how are you doing I
almost want to ask how are you doing
right now in the midst of this hurricane
that is the this movie in the life of
this movie that's a cool question so I
don't know I been surreal you know I
mean it's interesting just being at that
table with these guys and and with also
with Markus and McFeely and never you're
not always getting you know that lineup
and and everybody's like oh I love these
movies I love that movie or you know and
it's it and none of it would have been
obviously possible without so it's just
the fact that we've gone this far I
don't know you're I'm always thinking
like you know even if this is it this
has been pretty great but it's just been
very gratifying over and over and you
know we've all been together since the
beginning so last time I was here was
with Winter Soldier yeah that's amazing
yeah Wow
so this is family time family yeah
that's right do you believe it the last
time he was here in like the Winter
Soldier is one of the most popular
comic-con
characters like people it was really it
was that movie
I mean that kind of you know and that
was the movie yeah you know in Cleveland
that that put that character on the map
because before that I feel like Bucky
was you know it is but so I don't know
it's kind of strange hey you guys have
been here the last couple years right
yeah and I can't start to count up but I
think we're here with Winter Soldier
Civil War infinity war and then we
didn't come friend game
yeah now we're here we're here for the
you know this is a great moment because
endgame has had such a wonderful
theatrical run and now we're sort of
transitioning to the home release for
endgame so its it'll be nice it'll be an
interesting experience for people to
have the movie in their homes you know
after it being such an intense sort of
communal experience in the theaters well
and it's been so cool to have the
re-release and have some new content
come out with that you guys go see it in
the theater again how do you choose what
you want to add to the DVD content or
the home release content or or into a
rerelease for theaters we don't really
have a whole lot of choice because
there's not a lot of material would be
honest with you we most of what we shoot
makes it into the movie the movies are
exactly a lot of people ask us Oh is are
you ever gonna put out a director's cut
and Joe and I are just like then no the
the movie we released is the director's
cut baby welcome but there are a few
scenes they're always a few gems that
couldn't make it into the movie for very
specific reasons and we've got I think
we've got about five of them to release
with the home video release unbelievable
now Sebastian we talked about the Winter
Soldier you have you are Bucky and we're
in charge of a beloved beloved Marvel
character I have to ask in Marvel series
Avengers infinity where you at one point
pick up Rocket Raccoon a weapon wielding
rocket and spin in a circle and me and
my friends in the theater looked at each
other like what timeline it we get to
what that's one of the greatest images I
think in any movie I've ever seen what
was like when you hear you hear the news
I remember I remember cuz I was like wow
that's a great that that's the you know
that was like the moment the character
had sort of and it was a very cool
moment and and we were always kind of
toying with that because he's been so
serious since look it's another reason
why that infinity war for me I mean like
it's you have to say how hard it is to
me like how do you how do each of these
characters have like a moment that
advances them but I think from my
character is important because you had
seen him a certain way and then here he
is with a raccoon right so it's not like
we can just jump in there and make him a
comedic sort of character altogether but
like it sort of propelled him forward in
in a more yet still grounded but
different way than we've seen him and so
but it was great because we had a
conversation you were like yeah I hope
that's gonna make the move and it was
obviously a lot sexier in the movie it
was with him with a stuffed animal with
that
spinning in a circle with a rubber gun I
pay money to see that footage
we're like here pick up this stuffed
raccoon it's gonna look great trust us
perfect perfect moment in time but you
know that that's a great moment to tie
it to give credit to our team whom we
make this movie with I think that moment
might have been originally pitched to us
by our stunt team do you remember Joe
yeah was yeah yeah where they were just
like here's here's here's an awesome
moment with Winter Soldier who James
Young has been like one of the most
devoted team members to Winter Soldier
all the way through crafting it and then
with rocket and we're just like yeah we
love it
brought it to Seb he loved it so yeah
well we all loved it also yeah so let's
talk about cell phones after the film
came out there were some videos that
popped up some behind the scenes footage
did you know that there were so many
cell phones and did you get any secret
footage when you were Ruffalo I'm always
late like hearing how he's apparently
like just rooting
yeah that time with secrets we asked you
guys a bunch of questions like and who's
the worst at keeping secrets into
everyone hands down said poor mark he
owns that there was like who did it
evans Ruffalo a couple people had some
behind-the-scenes videos Oh Pratt was
the first to do it and that's what it
was okay even because it was that crazy
we were all there so it was impossible
not to tape it but I could I couldn't
find one I was like you missed the trend
I'm saying anything any point looking
around go like this is theirs
okay there's Captain America there I'm
the winner so um Rocket Raccoon is gonna
be like that portals moment where all
these carriages coming a wedding scene
that's I still call it that bye laughs I
love it
who's getting married so I know it is
still that that's that's that's because
everybody was there and and you made
sure because it was that was like that
one shot we were like we're gonna have
the shot to make sure everybody knows
everybody was there the wedding scene
he's referring to as weed while we were
prepping the film and executing and
shooting the film we would always refer
to Tony Stark's funeral scene as the
wedding scene because it was good
camouflage for that scene and that
everybody's you know why are people
wearing formal dark clothes
why is everybody gathering at on the
lake here oh it's a wedding
black and white a Michelle Pfeiffer
showed up to be an extra in that shot
like we were like everyone was running
around sick like Michelle Pfeiffer sorry
did you see myself Pfeiffer we just
asked her to stand there and move the
camera through this crowd and I thought
what a what a waste of a show guys it's
been such a delight to talk to you guys
and just celebrate a little bit of
Marvel Studios Avengers end game you all
go see it in theaters this is your last
moment to say anything you want the
Marvel fans that are all watching live
say hello or anything you like this
you're here you thank you thank you
thank you for being so supportive of the
movies
and so supporter of the universe for the
last ten years we make these movies for
you guys so thank you so much and it is
really your it's your the passion that
you have for these films is a big part
of why this is a special experience for
all of us so thank you for that